بارقه امل جديده لمرضى الزهايمر فعلاج
المرض لم يعد مستحيلا كما كان في السابق
لقاح جديد يبشر بالعلاج للمره الاولى منذ
20 عاما بعد موافقه المشروطه لاداره
الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه على عقار
الزهايمر لكيمبي الذي طورته شركات
اليابانيه وبايوجين الامريكيه العلاج
الجديد اثبت فعاليته في ابطاء تقدم مرض
الزهايمر وليس فقط في تخفيف اعراضه بنسبه
27%
العقار الجديد صنع للمرضى الذين يعانون من
ضعف ادراكي خفيف وليس الخرف الشديد
الموافقه المبدئيه على العقار جاءت بناء
على المعايير المخبريه او البيولوجيه
عندما اثبتت مساهمته في ازاله الترسبات
الدماغ التي هي سمه مميزه لمرض الزهايمر
اللجنه استخدمت بيانات اكثر حداثه من
دراسه اجريت على 1800 مريض واظهر فيها
الاشخاص الذين تناولوا الدواء معدلا
انخفاض طفيف في تراجع مقاييس الذاكره
والحكم والاختبارات المعرفيه الاخرى
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات